no lights on inside westminster as the
enormous political challenge posed by
energy bills gets very real
with 10 days of the summer break to go
until mps return and a new leader is in
place the public can only watch and wait
for more clarity the chancellor can only
talk about possible options we need to
make sure that this isn't a sticking
plaster that for the long term we
continue to help the most vulnerable who
have no no cushion and that's what i'm
determined to do and we're working up
those options for both households and
for business for the incoming prime
minister
some support will come this autumn
announced by the previous chancellor
three months ago
an upfront discount worth 200 pounds
doubled to 400 pounds for everyone
but on the campaign trail in
cambridgeshire he conceded those numbers
were already long out of date as
chancellor announced significant support
to help people but the situation is
deteriorated as prime minister i would
go further
liz trust whose team could be seen today
at chevening the foreign secretary's
grace and favor residents stayed away
from the cameras telling a newspaper she
would provide more support with bills
immediately if she wins but with no
further details
the key question is who will get this
help this analysis shows what the
candidates have committed to so far
liz truss wants tax cuts which would
disproportionately help those on higher
incomes
her rival rishi sunax proposals are more
targeted at the poorest but it's unclear
how much they'll be scaled up
labour say the government should freeze
bills for everyone regardless of their
circumstances
why should people on six-figure salaries
get their bills frozen let me challenge
this idea this assumption that most
people are going to be able to simply
pay the additional bills they'll suck it
up they won't really notice
these
average prices uh are going to go up to
3 500 pounds in october
the prime minister has already been
packing his bags and says it's on the
next occupant of number 10 to make these
key decisions
the cost of living will be the defining
issue for his successor as the weather
turns cold and energy prices are
expected to jump again during the
winter a clear out is expected at the
top of government
as families wait for their next bill to
drop what support they can rely on from
those in power is not a remotely clear
picture tomorrow cohen sky news
westminster